storytelling and public speaking where
are you struggling right now how do I
say one story stick with it to have the
call to action what I want people to
gain from it because I can tell stories
but I haven't quite figured out how to
make it work for the other person so the
best stories that you say from stage are
the ones where you are helping people
first right like the best stories that
I've told are because I help people
one-on-one first because when you're
speaking live on stage to a group of
people you don't get a lot of fantastic
feedback like you can kind of look at
their faces and see what's going on but
they have a lot of thoughts but they're
not expressing them but when you sit
down with somebody one-on-one you get
the feedback you get to see what they're
thinking you get to hear the real
thoughts going on in their head the
stories that I tell on stage the stories
I just told in Vegas I've told countless
times to people one-on-one and I know
how to tell the story so that it moves
them to a result you can have a million
different stories and it's awesome that
you're a Storyteller story's point is to
get people to move towards some kind of
action so the key is figuring out which
story to tell in which context If You're
Gonna Go on stage and speak what's the
end goal that you want to have happen
and then what's the right Story to Tell
in this situation
does that make sense
I'm figuring it out
I would practice telling more stories to
more individual people
and ask them what they thought
gotcha and especially the resistance
like where does it not make sense
okay I'll tell you a quick story
okay
I had eye surgery
um
the end of last month
and when I went to my doctor's office he
said I could go back to work I work in
the ER and I decided I need a doctor's
note
not to work till July so that I can sit
with what I really want to do with this
in this space
and so
the story for me is I have no income
so I have to figure
if I really want to be in this space or
not because just the way to help people
is to be able to be consistent and to
have a way to pay my bills otherwise I'm
not going to be in this space I'll go
back because every time I'm in the year
I can't I can't fit into this space it's
a different Zone
so the story
for me is to tell people that are 60
years old in healthcare that they need
to live their best life
even though they've lived a best a
better life in something they know it's
okay to Pivot
because if you don't
what are you going to do at the end of
life
and so I mean that that's I mean that's
why I did it that's the story I told
myself
and so I'm just trying to figure
how to take life situations and make it
stories to help people
make decisions and I made that decision
to say I burned that bridge is it a
permanent bridge I think it is
but I have to make it work
that's why I came on the call
no I love it and
your your journey
becomes the story so a couple things in
there right like you haven't done the
thing yet right you haven't built the
successful career outside of healthcare
yet no so we can't say here's what I've
done you know look at what I've done
but
the story is that you have the courage
to try
and the willingness to try
and you're going to make mistakes and
you're going to have self-doubt and
you're going to not be sure if it's
working out or not
and the willingness to try is the
inspiration
so
if if we're telling a story
if my main call Action was I want people
to be willing to try like if that's the
message be willing to try we're going to
try right you can have tons of stories
but my takeaway from this one is hey be
willing to try
so when our people are around you or
they hear your speech or they watch your
video I need to feel like I I should go
off I've got an idea I need to be
willing to try if Dr O's going to go off
and do it and and I need to be willing
to try as well
so the message is be willing to try then
you can tell a story around it gotcha
let me tell you guys I I'm I'm here
trying to I'm trying to do it too like I
haven't started living my life yet I'm
trying I don't know all the steps I'm
trying to figure it out I know that I
don't want to see any ER anymore
because it makes me feel X like whatever
it actually makes you feel
and I know I want to be in a different
spot and I'm tired of of people telling
me that I'm too old
and I'm tired of telling myself that I'm
told and that I can't change
and then whatever whatever like the
actual thoughts are in your head that
when you wake up because you don't wake
up every day and like I'm gonna go crush
this goal it's like what what are the
actual thoughts in your head because
that's what brings us in and makes it
personal okay
and then you share and I'm I still get
up every day because I'm willing to try
and I want to make this happen
so that when I walk away I've been
inspired by the story
but my takeaway is be willing to try
gotcha thank you very much now when
you're talking to somebody one-on-one
then you can ask for feedbacks like okay
so what are you gonna do now
and you see what this are they actually
off ready to try something or are they
still dealing with their own doubts and
insecurities
because when you're speaking on stage
again you're speaking to a a group of
people you don't get that feedback
but if you can if you can structure you
have so many stories to tell cool they
don't all have to fit into one video or
one speech
one main message per video per speech
that when I walk away with if you think
like the event I just came back from in
Vegas
it's like it was three days four days I
don't remember so many speakers
everybody gets up there's another speech
another speech that's like it's speech
overload like you guys have all been to
events and it's just crazy speech
overload so to to
hope that somebody remembers everything
that you're going to say is impossible
so it's like what's the one thing that
I'm going to get from your message
that I can take away that you are you
were the most valuable person for me
from that event
and it's such that you having that
intention as opposed to just standing up
saying I got a bunch of stories to tell
gotcha good luck all right milco in the
house I saw him bouncing what do we got
Milko my question it's not very well
formed uh but
for me because from what I know a good
storytelling you need to show emotions
and it's kind of like last time we kind
of covered this and you showed us how
you actually took your 700 videos or
what was them or something like that to
find your uh self and be yourself on
camera so for me because I usually I'm
not used to sharing my emotions in any
way so I usually uh I'm usually quite
intense when I coach people but I don't
share my emotions and I know that for
example for storytelling when you show
your emotions when you share them uh
it's much better and people can relate
to you more so I'm trying to
find this voice but I can't really make
the difference because sometimes I I
feel like I'm really putting it there
and I'm kind of showing my emotions and
stuff like that and then it turns out
the video that it's not uh or someone
else is telling me that it's not really
it sounds a bit a bit uh not genuine and
so on so so kind of I'm not sure where
I'm going with this but you know
so listen I mean if you if you go back
and watch our session from a couple
weeks ago is you know like I
self-criticized my videos or critique
them going back and and uh when I got
the feedback to have more motion you see
my very my very beginning videos that
the content was still almost to what I
talked about now
the delivery was way off it's like okay
guys so I got a question from my reader
and you know it's like it's just super
boring watching it back and then when I
got the feedback to try to do more
motion it felt forced right like as I
was critiquing my videos like look at
that video like I'm trying there is more
energy but it's not real Evan energy
it's a forced energy but it's it's
better than what it was but it's not
where it needs to be and it's still
pushing through that discomfort to uh
practice and work on it because it was
80 there some of the things are right
but I had to keep
I had to keep trying it on to like make
make it fit for me one of the best
things that helped me and this advice I
told Alex too who's in the house so we
could talk about him
um when Alex first started doing stories
at TDS uh China van salsa he was he was
doing stories at the front of the class
I was doing stories on videos it all
sucked I mean like what we all suck at
the beginning right and Alex and Alex
can add to the chat if he wants kind of
sharing stuff but
um it was really bad and and the points
were still good but the delivery was
just really really bad
um and so the exercise I gave him was
whenever you feel the emotion film
so whenever you feel like that
Breakthrough video for me to figure out
what number was like 670 something
um
was because I came back from that event
I was trying to help entrepreneur I was
so frustrated and so I I just filmed I
had no idea what I was gonna say and I
just filmed and the energy was on point
the content wasn't as good but the
energy was so much better
and it's the energy that's actually
going to carry the day and so whenever
you feel the emotion if if you just come
out of movement makers and you feel
grateful or you just come out of a
coaching call and you feel frustrated or
whatever has happened like you feel
emotions throughout your day
they just may not be there when you're
about to press record on the camera
so the trick is have your phone with you
which we probably all do and and when
you feel that emotion you film
and it does two things
one it it gets you
the practice of speaking from your heart
because we're speaking from our head
with most of our videos so it gets you
the practice of speaking with your heart
and letting that Express because you
feel what it feels like but you you
haven't practiced vocalizing what it
feels like and so it gets you that
practice the second thing is when you go
to try to tell that story again if
you're gonna then tell that story on
stage you can tell that story in a
future video you can go back and watch
how you delivered it when you were
actually in that state and then you can
think back to yeah that's how I felt
because it's hard to manufacture that
sometimes when you're just sitting at
home on your ball kind of bouncing
around figuring out you know talking
about food choices right
um so that's the best activity that I
would recommend it's like try to catch
it during the week and then film even if
you don't post it just try to catch an
emotion any uh a positive or negative
emotion
and film it and don't stress if it sucks
and don't stress if it's not well
thought out or
um you don't really know what you're
saying as you go but just practice that
because the more you practice that the
better you'll get at it and again you
can go watch it back and say yeah that's
what it feels like to to have that that
thought again so you could get out of
your head and into your heart
thank you so very helpful yeah I
remember one time where like when I was
really grinding on Alex to do this we're
at a uh we're at a dance event so we we
hosted these dance parties once a week
or so and um he was uh
uh he I forget he had some kind of
emotion right he was upset or he was
happy I don't remember what it was like
dude go film like now yeah go go film
now and and then he he filmed yeah it's
like that's what you need to train
yourself to do you're feeling emotional
film film even if it's just for yourself
to get the repetition down
today guys we have a super super super
important topic when to push
versus when to break and this is a
really important one because
I think uh
we have moments where we are our best we
have moments where we are showing up
where we are motivated we're inspired
where we're doing our thing where we
know that what we're doing is important
where we feel the impact maybe you join
movement makers and you've got a lot of
inspiration from the session maybe
somebody left you a great comment but
then there's going to be days when you
wake up and you don't feel like it and
you don't have the energy and it's not
as high and you you have that voice
inside your head that says
tomorrow do it do it tomorrow right it's
okay you deserve a break you've been
working too hard
what do you do when that voice comes in
when all your friends tell you to take
it easy to relax and take a break I have
a rule
where I want to spend 95 of my time
pushing harder and five percent of my
time giving myself a break because there
are definitely some times we actually
really do need a break we need to take
care of yourself where you need to relax
we've actually pushed too hard and
that's okay but most of the time I think
you need to push harder I think that's
the mindset of high Achievers and I'm
going to break down today some of the
stories just my own experience you can
learn from as well as some strategies
you can use to help you identify when to
push harder and when to break so first
thing I'm going to talk about here how
did the side between pushing versus
breaking
pass the pillow test
so let's dive in so again 95 push five
percent break this is my own internal
metric this is what I tell myself
95 of the time when I'm feeling low
energy tired don't feel like doing it
have have every excuse in the world not
to do it every reason everybody else
left me off the hook 95 of the time me
Evan Carl Michael emotionally the voice
in my head is
go do it
you have to go do it this becomes an
identity thing
this is who I want to be Evan Carmichael
at his best self is the guy who's off
pushing for one more
say no that little voice in my head and
then five percent is to take a break
take it easy it's okay to rest right uh
you can figure out what the numbers are
for you but for achievers
you guys got big movements ahead of you
it should lean more towards the push
than the break
so let me talk to you about Tuesday
we've been going through some crazy
times here at the Carmichael household
uh we just came back from a trip we went
out to uh to Kelowna our first family
trip in the past two years which is
which is amazing uh there's no Corona
out there at all so everybody's around
no masks in uh indoor dining all of it
we're here in Toronto's a lot of still
issues you can't do indoor dining we're
in masterfield we're going out there but
we come back here
I decided I want to redo my office and
redo my bedroom uh and do floors I want
new floors so you probably can't see
them from this angle because I moved my
desk and it's a little chaotic but we
got brand new floors in the office it
wasn't ready it was supposed to be ready
on Monday
we got the wrong floors it didn't work
so Tuesday was a disaster
Tuesday is normally my YouTube filming
day
okay
we can't sleep on our bedroom on Monday
night because they put half the floors
and they got to take them out I can't do
anything in our second bedroom because
it's full of all the junk from the first
bedroom and I can't do anything in my
third bedroom which is my office because
the floors are all ripped up here too so
we take our bed and put it down in the
kitchen the only spot and so we slept in
the kitchen
Monday night
okay Tuesday Morning Comes Around I had
a terrible sleep I'm still jet lagged
Nina's got an early morning acupuncture
apartment and Tuesday is my espresso
video guys I gotta go film espresso I
usually Drive Nina to wherever she needs
to go she goes and does her stuff and I
film videos in the car it's been our
tradition
she wakes up I am dead tired
and she said I'm gonna I'm gonna go you
sleep in a little bit I'll come back and
get you in a couple hours
this is the point when that little voice
really matters
because in my head I'm thinking I'm
tired I'm jet lagged
she's gonna come back in two hours and
I'll be able to film that anyway I can
still get it done right we we create a
logical reason how we can still follow
through I can still get it done
I'm sleeping in the kitchen
I deserve this I just came back this is
crazy but then literally 10 seconds
later it's like no I'm coming
I'm coming I'm coming I get up we rush
out and then I go and film videos and
instead of just making usually an
espresso day I'll make seven videos I
made 15.
just because just because that's what
Evan Carmichael does right and not that
I'm some superhero like it's it's
something that's been built
every time you have that little voice
inside your head that says Nah you know
you shouldn't do it like no
there's no reason why I can't
and then go a little bit harder push a
little bit more now I went a little
crazy because I was really in the zone
and I love when I'm in the zone I love
staying in the zone as much as possible
so instead of doing seven I finished off
the ten that were on my list and then I
asked for five more and then finish
those five as well
come on Evan Carmichael let's go right
and this is for for all of you the same
thing you have that little voice that
tells you you can't do it gives you all
the reasons why you can't
and then you show yourself that you can
and not just that you can do that thing
but you can do more
and what it does is start to shift the
identity
it starts to take away that little voice
in your head so that it doesn't have to
take you I used to lose an entire day I
never lost weeks or months right but I
would lose an entire day some one little
thing happened that that derailed me the
whole day would be gone like okay I'll
figure it out tomorrow
the goal is to try to get that to as
shorter window as possible
so instead of I take an entire day for
you to bounce back it's you know a
couple hours to then an hour to then
half an hour to then five minutes to
then you know 15 seconds you know stuff
is going to happen
the the answer is not to avoid all of
the pains in life stuff is going to
happen to you it's how do you react to
them and then get back on track
showing yourself that you're the person
who does it
so I want to share a recent example
because that just happened Tuesday the
the most painful examples back in 2019
when I broke my neck and I had a goal of
going live every day on Instagram I said
on my tour I'm gonna go live every
single day on Instagram every day 90
days every day I'm going live on
Instagram no matter what little did I
know I was going to be in the hospital
with the concussion and break my neck in
two spots but that no matter what
made me want to do it
and this was me I broke my neck on
Nina's birthday March 15th is Nina's
birthday and we broke my neck and was in
the hospital and I said I need to go
live and the doctor was like you can't
go live and Nina's like you're crazy
what are you doing like no no I said I
was gonna go live every day I can't even
see the phone at this point right I've
got a concussion I don't know what's
happened on the screen but even if it's
for 60 seconds
I'm gonna go live and most of my live
streams were an hour long right
I don't know how long this one ended up
being was probably a couple minutes I
just gave people a quick update it looks
like I'm dying
so Doug watler who's a movement maker
and long time you know friend uh took
this screenshot and posted his Instagram
he's like Doug I look like I'm dead I
mean he took it in black and white for
whatever reason I wasn't filming in
black and white and posted it but what
I'm I'm happy and I see you know Adam
Duran who gave a thumbs up in the chat
here on this picture uh who's also now
Movie Makers welcome board Adam this
might have been might have been crazy uh
might have been too stupid
but I'm proud of it it was probably the
worst live stream I've ever done I don't
know what I said it was probably very
incoherent just telling people what
happened
and then I'm gonna be okay
but it was likely my worst livestream of
all time but one of the ones that I'm
most proud of because there was every
reason why I couldn't do it and then I
still went and did it right
so fast forward March 29th so two weeks
later I'm back to filming videos
now they're not the most coherent videos
I'm not the best on camera I'm wearing
this neck brace I've got this giant scab
on my forehead right I look at myself
how many times have you looked at
yourself and like I can't make videos
today because what because my hair is a
little bit out of place
looking at you Alex
because because I gained a little bit of
weight because whatever right I'm
sitting here with a neck brace on
there's Alex taking his hat out there we
go you know with this giant scab on my
forehead like let's go right and I had
that guys I had that voice too it's like
I can't make a video with this crazy
thing on my forehead with this neck
brace on I can't even fit into my
clothes I'm wearing I might be naked
under this I'm not sure but I may I
might have a t-shirt on I couldn't lift
my arms to get anything on I couldn't
put my my usual believe hoodie on so I
put on a jacket
this is an Arizona or something this is
like super warm
but I'm wearing a jacket
start making videos because I had that
voice in my head again telling me you
can't do this look at you you're a mess
everybody would every who would not
understand right like everybody would
understand if I didn't make content
given what happened but I don't want
that like that's the standard I was on a
walk with with Nina this morning taking
the dogs up before coming here and she's
like your standards are just way up here
this is a normal person and your
standards are in the sky it's like yes
exactly that's what we want and by you
raising your standards you lift
everybody else up around you as well so
it's not that I don't have these voices
I still have those voices telling me I
can't do it and and all the reasons why
I can't it's fighting that voice every
single day
by April uh the scab was gone uh I still
can't fit into my hoodie so I I went to
the store I was tired of filming and
just my one jacket so we went to a store
and we bought this giant like double XL
Nike sweater
that was the only thing I could fit into
on a day-to-day basis so you can see it
there I've gained some weight like look
at me I'm barely moving guys my I'm my
pillow's behind me I'm in so much pain
every day we're continuing the tour look
at how much look at my face look at how
much weight I've gained so now I'm
self-conscious about my weight I've just
gained 15 pounds because I'm lying on
the on the couch all day because I can't
move I can't film now I can't film being
this fat Evan
again Voice to my head no I have to do
it now because that was in my head now I
have to do it because that was the
reason
I refuse to not make content because of
that voice I refuse to play small
because of that voice right could I take
a break yes is this where I'm proud of
myself for taking a break no so I'm
gonna make videos
and then fast forward to may now I'm I'm
healing a little bit more you can see I
lost some weight on my face if you go
back uh I'm at home now I can fit into
my shirts again I'm still wearing the
neck brace still healing but still
making content
still making content my health card we
have a photo health card here in Ontario
and when we got back I had to renew my
health card because my wallet was stolen
in LA on our trip and we'd get to the
place to take the picture and I'm
wearing my neck brace and he's like
don't you want to take your neck brace
off for for the camera because this is
going to be on your health card for the
next five years have you like scrunched
up here with this neck brace so I'm like
that on my health card for the next five
years like I showed up
take my picture that we all get
self-conscious of in my neck brace when
I could have taken it off just because
right like it's that daily constant
attacking of that little voice inside
your head telling you all the reasons
why that you can't win
okay so I filmed throughout the whole
thing there wasn't a time that I that I
took a a day off on filming now in 2019
October
my family my family dog died Toby and uh
he he passed away we put him down he had
really bad cancer he was struggling for
a long time and
um he passed away on on a Tuesday which
was our my filming day
it was the morning and it was my family
all there and um my dad and I stayed in
the room with with him while you know
they gave him the final injection and
everybody else left and it was super
emotional and I just
I couldn't imagine going home and
filming
you know and so I uh I told
Christina my editor let's do some
mashups we still have to get videos up
but let's do some content and let's just
explain it at the beginning that I I
skipped the filming day you know so we
wrote this Toby my family dog my
family's dog passed away from cancer
this week I didn't do my regular
espresso filming I hope you understand
I love you too but you still can't
believe you're gone thank you for an
amazing 11 years and I'm still kind of
getting a little
choked up just looking at it
but I was okay with um with not filming
on that day
you know I was okay with it
like this is where I would film through
a broken neck I would film through
everything else but but um
you know for me this was the moment
where like okay in the past however many
years this is the time that I'm not I'm
not filming and I'm okay with that
now for those of you who have dogs maybe
you get what I'm saying for those of you
you might think I'm crazy
um
that's okay too
it's not judging somebody else's reasons
it's are you proud of yourself
for why you didn't do it I'm okay that I
didn't film that week we still got
videos up I'm okay with it
that was a five percent
right 95 push five percent break I'm
okay with that five percent being a
break
we're gonna talk about something super
super super important today about how to
collab with the right people so you guys
have big movements big missions Big
Ideas big things in front of you we want
to go change the world and we need help
doing it you know I think one of the
challenges that we face is we try to do
everything ourselves you're trying to do
everything yourself you're trying to
wake up do your morning routine you know
watch your videos put the music on and
just go out and do it and that's great
yes awesome and one of the fastest ways
to grow is to find people who already
have your audience
we're already talking to your customers
and find a way to work together
doing your grind doing your calls doing
your emails creating your content yes I
love it and when you can get the right
collaborations and Alliance Partners it
can really turbo speed your movement
it may take a little longer to get it
off the off the ground Alliance
Partnerships and one of the hardest
things to get going
but once you do that could be an ongoing
source of attention of traffic of leads
of customers for you forever so that's
what we're talking about today I'm so
excited let's Dive In
think about who you want to talk to who
you want to connect with who if they
knew who you were would make a
meaningful impact on your business
if this person said you have to check
out Frank Villas art would make a
meaningful impact
on your business Frank's flashing a few
signs we love you Frank
think about those people okay that's who
we need to start connecting with that's
we need to start hanging out with but
then the question becomes well how do I
get to know these people because I don't
have connections I don't know anybody I
remember when I first went uh in my very
very very first business I went to the
bank
and ask for help
and he said well do you need what Genie
alone like oh I don't know I'm just
starting my business you know your bank
you're here to help me right I'm I need
help
and he said no we we give out loans but
you need to have at least three years in
business before you can really qualify
unless you want to put a personal
guarantee on it and so that kind of shut
down my my hopes like oh okay I guess
it's gonna be a lot harder than I
thought I was going to be getting into
this so how do you get access to these
people right step one is you want to
hang out where they hang out and what
you want to do is look for the platform
where they are the most involved so
everybody all the people that you want
to connect with they're on social media
right that's that's the beauty of living
in 2021
2022 2023 they're on social media
they're more accessible than ever
the traditional roots of trying to track
down a phone number
right is now impossible don't worry
about that but you can connect with
people on Instagram or on YouTube or on
Twitter on clubhouse but most people are
everywhere think about your own
experience you're probably everywhere
you probably have an account on all
these platforms but you're not actually
involved
and for the bigger people it's most
likely their teams who are doing most of
the stuff
so what you want to do is look for the
platform where they are the most
involved personally not just in posting
like great they're posting on Twitter
they're posting on YouTube awesome where
they actually
personally involved in the discussion
the easiest way to find that out is by
the comments
where are they actually responding to
people's comments
where are they actually involved in the
discussion
and not just their team but it's them
that's where you want to hang out
because you can spend lots of time
hanging out
and just consuming the content
but we want to be hanging out in the
same room that they're actually hanging
out and you might not be invited to all
the big parties in the fancy Jets and
you know whatever else
but social media is a part that's open
to everybody
you need to be hanging out where you're
not just Heroes and mentors and Masters
you can learn from but collaborators are
hanging out
okay so I want to tell a quick story
about Mark Jager he's a fellow Movie
Maker friend of mine for over a decade
Mark has an ambition to be the world's
greatest host he wants to host people he
wants to host people on stage he wants
all those people having good
conversations Marcus had a podcast on
and off I don't know for five years
seven years I don't know he's had a
podcast on and off forever
nothing ever really took off because in
just starting a podcast you're one of
many
you won't have many
it's hard to stand up
so his next step was to collaborate with
me
Clubhouse came out I actually pushed him
to say mark this is Audio Only You Love
Audio Only You need to get on clubhouse
now
while it's still young while you can
still stand out while there's still so
much demand and so little good Supply
you need to get on now and start having
these conversations and start hosting
rooms so step one was him to create a
clubhouse account step two was him to
start using my account where we're
leveraging all of the videos that we've
done on YouTube and broadcast them to
Clubhouse
what led to that happening was Grant
Cardone Pops in a room
less brown Pops in a room
and Mark starts having conversations
with them
so he leveraged my name to create my
grant cardone's top 50 rules of success
and my Les Brown's top 50 rules for
Success broadcast him on clubhouse right
Mark was just doing the tech behind it
leveraged my name to do it Grant Pops in
the room
twice
and Mark then has a conversation
with Grant
getting access to Grants is very
difficult if you were to email his
office and say hey I'd love to talk to
grant for a couple minutes
[Laughter]
good luck making that happen right but
because Grant's attention was on
clubhouse at the moment it was an easy
way for Mark to start to have that
conversation Les Brown this is an even
better story Les Brown pops in
Mark has another great conversation
which leads to less wanting to partner
up which led to us doing
two more less brown only q and A's
whereas me Mark Les and his son John
Leslie the first one lasted a couple
hours the second one we did we had the
we had to narrow down the time scope
because I had the runs it was like an
hour an hour and a half but now Mark
is hosting
Les Brown
on his channel where he spent seven
years or whatever podcasting not really
getting traction now all of a sudden is
hosting the Les Brown because he's
hanging out where Les Brown is hanging
out
you have to be where your audience not
just where your audience with the people
you want to collab with are hanging out
that's the keys he's got the skill set
he always had the skill set
now Mark this weekend
is flying to Les Brown's event and
helping host his event live on stage
with Les Brown
right yeah you guys can top that up how
cool is that
he went from just having years of
podcasting not getting any traction to
then getting on clubhouse leveraging
leveraging my content
getting to connect with less hosting
Less in a couple of Clubhouse rooms to
now being invited to go host with less
live at one of Les Brown's events and
Les Brown to me is one of the greatest
of all time young Les Brown is the
greatest speaker of all time in my books
where he falls for you is open for
debate but I mean he's got to be in the
top 10 of all time now Mark is
facilitating those conversations because
he was hanging out where they hang out
this is how quickly it can happen
when you start to get into the right
circles
okay
Evan tinsman so Evan tinsman came this
is Evan movement makers the first
movement maker Evan tinchman was the
first mover maker he came to my event in
Pittsburgh this was his first video on
his YouTube channel if you go to his
channel and you go go all this video
you'll see this video which was him
January 2019 I went to Pittsburgh it was
cold and a lot and I kicked off my event
my tour this is where I broke my neck we
did 90 days on the road all of that
stuff 23 cities this is the first stop
this is Evan's Nursery it's 20 seconds
long
don't make 20 second long videos on
YouTube guys you know now we know we
know but this is great this is just him
just before I get started that's me
about to get started on stage and Evan's
just doing a quick tour of the room
he came
to thank me for all the videos that I
had done I never met him before this
point but he had watched all of my
content or a good chunk of my content he
came just to say to say thank you he
knew I was coming to Pittsburgh this is
a chance to hang out we're the people
you want to connect with are hanging out
and really the motivation to come was
just just to say hi and say thank you
that's why he showed up
it led to him join in movement makers
led to him being a part of our
Mastermind now was for one year plus
members
and let them be giving him a quote for
his YouTube channel you know how many
people hit me up every day asking hey
can you be a testimonial hey can you
write the forward for my book hey can
you review my product hey and
it's not that I don't want to it's that
I don't know you
you know I don't know you I I
I don't like giving recommendations to
people who I've never met
even if they've been a hardcore loyal
fan of my channel if you haven't ever
contributed anything I I can't I don't
know who you are so
we took this picture in Pittsburgh
I then hung out with Evan the next day a
little bit and gave him a quote if you
want the steps to have a greater impact
follow-up in tinsman says Evan
Carmichael Evan and Evan
right
because he came to where I was hanging
out
that's what you wanted you make your
list of the top hundred people that you
want to connect with and then you're
staying on top of where are they hanging
out both virtually right
Mark did it to get the Grant Cardone and
Les Brown through Clubhouse Evan did it
by getting to me in person because I had
an event happening there
one other quick example this is Jeremy
who came to my thought Leadership
Academy this is this was the this is
what I did before Movie Makers I had
twice a year people coming to Toronto uh
and we trained 15 people at a time how
to be thought leaders uh you can see
Alex down here at the bottom Alex was
one of my my trainers as well uh but the
circle there is Jeremy and Jeremy came
at the time he was
uh earning minimum wage at a grocery
store stocking shelves hating his job
hating his life saved up his money I
didn't know any of his story till he
told me afterwards but saved up this
money to come to this event this is
three days a couple thousand dollars uh
and thought I need to hang out where
Evelyn is hanging out because Evan's
videos have impacted my life and got me
on a personal development Journey right
when he was struggling with frustration
his life he went to YouTube typed in
something like how do I make money
and started finding my videos and it led
him down this course of personal
development
so I really liked him he was the
youngest one there he was 20 maybe just
20 21 at this time
um hanging with a bunch of you know more
grown adults
and I really talked to him and I really
liked him and it led to us starting a
business together
and I remember I love this Vibe he told
me his story and I was on my tour and I
was thinking about him because he had
asked me Evan I want to spend more time
with you I came here to hang out with
you we're both in Toronto tell me what I
can do to spend more time with you I
will walk your dog I will clean your car
I will cut your grass I will do whatever
you need me to do I don't have very many
skills yet because I'm still young and
developing but whatever you want to do
whatever you need me for just I'm here
let me know and I told them dude I love
your energy I love your Vibe I don't
need somebody to walk my dogs you know
at least I'm gonna wash my car I don't I
don't I'm in a condo I don't have a lawn
but but the the vibe stock
you know the vibe stuck with me and so
when I'm doing my tour I'm driving
through the desert uh on my way to uh
New Mexico
and in the in the desert I had this idea
I'm gonna teach Jeremy how to do YouTube
I'm going to teach Jeremy how to be a
YouTube consultant
and I told Nina we need to get a two
percent difference like immediate action
I did action let's go I told Nina we
need Jeremy on a call right now
because if if we can't get him on a call
by the time I get to
Arizona not Arizona to New Mexico my
spot I see Frank I think in Arizona uh
if we can't get there in time
then I said I'm probably in a different
vibe in a different Zone like when
you're in the zone you have to start
taking that immediate action that's
where your Genius really comes out so we
got Jeremy on a Facebook call and I told
him my idea
and I still had two more months of my
tours like I can't do anything with you
for another two months because I'm I'm
doing my tour but here's what I need to
do I'm gonna send you all sorts of
resources my videos other people's
videos I want you to study everything I
want you to do your own research into
YouTube and the algorithm and when I
come back I'm going to mentor and train
you even more to build this business
and he did
right and we caught him off guard he was
out here I think he was working his
shift he's like yeah yeah I'm here what
do you think what happened
because he's stocking shelves at this
grocery store
and now he's got a half a million dollar
business
you know half a million a year
inside of
a year and a half two years of doing
this working with some of his Heroes
because he hung out where the people
that he wanted to hang out with were
right he wanted to meet me and he hung
with me this isn't just like oh Evan
Carmichael's so special this is this is
everybody this is you can you can get a
lot closer to touching your dreams when
you're hanging out with the people who
can make a difference for you Jeremy
knew nothing about YouTube at the time
now he's coaching some of the biggest
YouTube channels in the world
and thought leadership on how they can
grow their channels
he burned his apron he had to wear this
apron every day you know there's this
outfit he burned the aprons like I'm
never going back there and he had this
really emotional moment where he made
more in one month than he did an entire
year working you know full-time as a
grocery store clerk right
um and it's not the skill set because he
had none it's just the desire and the
willingness to show up
movement makers great to see you again
okay so we're on to something
pretty exciting today this was an
interesting topic that I think really
holds a lot of people back you guys
especially for Achievers because you
guys know
you guys know you're capable of more and
you know that you're you're pushing
other people to do great things and at
the same time you're not doing all the
things that you should be doing right is
that does that relate it's like you know
that you could be doing more
you know you know that you're doing more
than your friends and the people around
you but how many days you go maybe even
days or weeks in a row where it's like
okay I I played small I was afraid
I didn't do what I should have right and
we beat ourselves up and and the point
isn't to just lay more beats on you the
point is to be able to make progress and
so today's theme which I'm super excited
by is how to build the resilience
mindset to overcome obstacles and get
back up quickly let's dive in one of the
things I get asked the most when I do
podcasts interviews uh I'm on somebody's
show Clubhouse they say what are your
non-negotiables you know what's the
thing that you have to do every single
day or what's your morning routine and
what what is non-negotiable has to
happen all the time
and I don't really have anything that's
absolutely non-negotiable I think the
closest thing is
connection to Nina
if I look at our relationship over the
past decade I don't know that there's
been a single day that I haven't
connected with Nina
now obviously when I'm home that's easy
but when I'm traveling and I'm away
every day at least I'm checking in once
just to see how she's doing even on the
craziest of crazy days but apart from
that
there's nothing that has to be every
single day and I think one of the
challenges that we come up with for
ourselves is we feel like we have to be
perfect we got perfectionists in the
house
you perfectionist because I know I am
I'm a recovering perfectionist you know
I lost a 40 million deal when I was 20
because I was trying to be perfect and I
still want things to be perfect the
problem is when we don't hit our mark
what we end up doing is nothing
you know when we don't actually go and
accomplish what we want we don't want to
feel like a loser we don't want to feel
less than and so we just spend our time
on something else instead of actually
starting to build momentum for the
dreams that we have so
I found this awesome graphic of the
perfect morning routine you know like
wake up before you have to and go make a
cup your happy beverage spend time doing
something you enjoy say something nice
about yourself go let's try to get some
sun eat a good breakfast be kind to
yourself open your windows wipe write
down how you can best meet your needs
for the day then we have this this
concept of what a perfect one routine is
and that's great but this might take two
hours and we don't always follow through
perfectly I am never a hundred percent
on my morning routine every month if you
look at my my morning routine and what I
do every month there's I don't think
there's been a single month where I'm
getting it 100 of the time
and that's normal
and that's fine and that's okay
it's not expecting to be perfect but
it's expecting to do the best that we
can
because life will throw circumstances at
you uh life will throw obstacles at you
and what we often do when we're trying
to be perfect again is we're either
perfect or we're nothing
and that's a problem and there are a few
days where we can be perfect there are a
few days where you can get your perfect
days down
but then what happens when you come up
against some obstacle
what often happens too much even for
Achievers we're talking Achievers here
we're not talking to people who have no
goals no aspirations no dreams achievers
will still do nothing
because it can't be perfect
and so I want to start to
blur that line a little bit so it's not
perfect or zero that we're always trying
to do the best we can so we're proud of
our effort
I saw this and I love that if the
version of you from five years ago could
see you right now they'd be so proud
keep going
and this is often what we need to remind
ourselves of when you when you feel like
you're not perfect when you feel like
you're not getting results when you feel
like you let yourself down your family
down your community down the people
around you down
that's the time to reflect back and say
hey where was I five years ago look at
all of you five years ago where were you
come on now
compared to what you're doing right now
the the projects you're working on the
adventures you're involved in the
communities you're a part of the you
from five years ago would not recognize
do you right now today
and sometimes we have to remind
ourselves of that
when we fall off of our perfect horse
how do you get back up quickly right
this is the theme of the day
you remind yourself of the journey that
you've been on
because what we need to do is get back
to the consistency
so you get back on the horse and keep
going how do we get back on the horse
this will help
look at the journey look at how much
you've grown look at how much you've
done look at how much you've
accomplished look at all the lives that
you've impacted the people that you've
helped how much you've learned and grown
and gotten better
because it helps to get rid of the pity
party that I'm not perfect now I didn't
do it so now I'm zero
it's not zero or a hundred right 97 is a
great score
let's remind ourselves of that and keep
going because the consistency is going
to be the thing that gets you to where
you go
it's not the perfect
it's the consistency that we'll get to
where you need to go
Terry I'm definitely in a different
space from five years ago I love it
Pablo in the house says hola
Marcus recovering perfectionist listen I
think everybody here is a recovering
perfectionist
I think Achievers are perfectionists
we want we know it can be better we want
it to be better
and so this is how we stop getting in
our own way this is a great quote I came
across from Cassie Stevens who's um art
teacher she's a she's a creator
she said we see kids start to become
perfectionists and we see them start to
struggle we need to guide the way for
them
and keep the joy in art
and this is a great message for kids but
it's also a great message for you
it's a great message for you like how
many adults how many thought leaders how
many creators how much great art of
yours has not come out because you are
struggling with being a perfectionist
I know there's lots of things that I
didn't release
especially early on because I was afraid
it wasn't good enough it wasn't perfect
that would be critiqued that I could do
better
and as a result I didn't release it
this isn't just a kids thing this is
this is a human thing and again
especially for achievers
because we want to achieve we want to we
want to win we want to get the gold
medal you know we want the results
and we're afraid to release something
that doesn't get the results
but that becomes the game because a lot
of the things that you create
you never know if it's actually going to
win or not a lot of my best videos I
would all of the best videos on my
channel I would never have pegged to say
that's the one that's going to win never
and a lot of the ones that I love the
most didn't
do well you know it's like man really
you guys don't like that video come on
now I love that one
so it makes a really big difference you
just get your art out there
to stop judging to stop critiquing and
just release and what I find really
helpful with this is
tomorrow you release again and the next
day you release again and the next day
you release again so it's not so much
pressure on this one thing being perfect
because you're going to create another
one and another one and another one and
another one we need to put the art
back into your content
okay when you overthink it and try to
make it perfect all the time you suck
the creativity the art out of it
creativity is messy R is messy it's not
going to be perfect at the beginning
that's the whole point and we struggle
we struggle with that
so what helps is just not expecting to
be perfect don't expect it to be
especially the beginning
don't expect it to be perfect that's why
we do the 100 video challenge I want you
to expect to suck at the beginning like
just expect to suck
Release Yourself of the burden of it
being fantastic expect it to be terrible
expect to look back on your first video
and be embarrassed
but after you get through 10 after you
get through 20 after you get through 50.
after you get to 100 you look back and
say holy cow I got so much better people
who've gone through the 100 video
challenge even a couple videos in 10
videos in
start to say wow I'm already so much
better
I made it too big a project and as a
result I did nothing
so stop expecting to be perfect sing
your own song because you can sing Alan
says five years ago I had not met Evan
progress over Perfection says do I love
it you can't mess up art because you can
always paint over it and do it again
on on so right now
I had to remind myself of that going
into what I'm doing right now because
I've been with my son for the past few
weeks and we've got
a little more time together before he
starts to go back to school and I wanted
to really make it count and as a result
I have done
very little on my business usual stuff I
got way ahead on YouTube so content is
coming up got way ahead on Instagram all
that stuff so content is coming up but
I'm not doing my Ig lives I'm not doing
uh any podcasts any interviews I'm not
meeting with my team I'm not doing all
the stuff that I usually do that I that
I love to do it I don't see it as work
you know when I meet with Alex or Drew
on a Monday it's not like oh
man gotta meet that Alex guy
[Laughter]
you see it as work this this is what I
love to do this is great
but I also wanted to be intentional with
my time while Hayden is here
and as a result
um I knew I wouldn't be able to keep up
on my usual commitments and so Angela
sent this amazing message to me on my
DMs on Instagram that I wanted to share
it's like okay I get it I get it man
believe nation is missing you you are
missed on Instagram 2PM is so boring you
are loved so glad you're enjoying your
family time everyone looks really happy
so good to see you love you all and
she's saying that because two o'clock
Eastern I would go live on Instagram
two o'clock Eastern I go live on
Instagram uh it's either me with a guest
or me sometimes movement makers pop in
and we do a round table which is super
fun or I just coach people live it's I
never know what's going to happen on a
Tuesday all right sorry Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Friday doing my Instagram
lives but
I'm not doing it I haven't done it in
three weeks
Mr consistency hasn't done it in three
weeks
because I'm trying to be intentional and
spend that time with my son so apart
from movement makers brand lytics
um I'm not doing any of my usual
commitments and so some people Angel is
very warm and loving this is a great
message some people aren't as warm or
loving some people are more attacking
and critical it's like yo where are you
where's where's the Instagram lives how
when do I get my turn it's like come on
I'm I'm doing something else right now
um and so I'm not
trying to be perfect
I'm not going in thinking I can do
everything but I'm trying to be
intentional with the time that I'm
spending
so don't expect to be perfect if you
want to watch the full version of this
video as well as train live with me
twice a month to help you build your
movement and be around some other
amazing people just like you check out
my movement makers program the link to
join is right there next to me can't
wait to see you there continue to
believe and go join